this is clearly good evening this is
clearly a very difficult time for the
SMP I mean today was an important day
um for the for the first Minister
setting out his policy agenda as you'd
expect you know it's the first Tuesday
back after the Easter recess his first
real opportunity to make a statement and
set out his policy agenda he did that
there was a lot of detail in that
there'll be a bit of slow burn but
there's no question that the background
to it was incredibly difficult for the
party and now there's a significant task
ahead of the Westminster elections
probably next year and the Scottish
parliamentary elections the years from
now for Hamza Yusuf to set out who he is
what his tasks are as first Minister and
to try and regain the front fruit but
there's no question that this is this is
difficult at the moment
um do you think that Hamza Yusuf was
fairly or unfairly framed as the
continuity candidate and do you think
that the party might regret all opting
for someone who has been framed in that
way given that clearly there's some
baggage from the the previous leadership
well let's not forget the framing of
this you know when Nicholas sturgeon
left office and who knows how this will
pan out over the coming weeks and months
when Nicholas Thurston left office she
left office with popularity ratings and
poll ratings that any Westminster Party
would have given their High teeth for
you know and significant poll leads
having won eight elections on the Trot
she went out as a popular first minister
so I think that is SM you know SMP
members saw that Legacy of success saw
the way that that transformed Scotland
from a policy perspective and they
rather liked it and that's why Hamza was
elected so you can see why Hamza would
have wanted to frame themselves as a
continuity candidate the first Minister
was not leaving or sorry the previous
first Minister nickel sturgeon was not
leaving because she was unpopular she
was leaving because she'd chosen that
was the time of our exit so I think that
perspective around it is sometimes quite
quite helpful now things happen fast in
politics
um and that's why it's a job of
politicians to try and keep up
what I mean so you mentioned there what
do you make now in light of recent
events of the timing and the framing of
the reasons for Nicholas surgeon's exit
well Nicholas surgeon had put in a shift
I I think first of all if you take the
recent Revelations and and instantly of
course the rules around discussing
police investigations in Scotland are
much stricter than they are
um in in England for example but
Nicholas sergeant had put in a shift
remember this was a first Minister who
had gone through the brexit the brexit
disaster the field breaks experiment and
positioned the party quite well
um around that this was also a first
Minister who had taken the lead through
covet and if you look at leaders in
Democratic societies throughout the
world covered played
um and played a heavy price on
politicians now as well as Frontline
staff as well but she did not go through
her periods of first Minister during
an easy time she had brexit she had
covered she had all the other challenges
and I think when she left she said she
was knackered I I think I believed her
when she said that
um and so I I can understand why she
wanted to leave I I'm sure she was uh
absolutely naked as you said she put in
a good shift that's the understatement
of of the century but I guess my point
is do you think she had some knowledge
uh that the writing might be on the wall
and that there might be a need for a
change with these sorts of things coming
down the pipe or not
I'm that's not something I'm I'm aware
of and obviously there's a live police
investigation at the moment but that's
not something I'm aware of so I have no
knowledge that she was aware of of of
these things I can well believe that
given the shift that you put in given it
was three years to another
um parliamentary election that you
thought that was probably quite a good
time to go I think she thought that
Independence needed another push because
despite the fact the s p got winning
election after election and is this you
would see a mandate after mandate that
no Independence referendum was
forthcoming from Westminster she
probably thought that a Fresh Approach
was what was needed to go in the next
stage of that Journey so I I believe
that's why I should step down you can
see why she was exhausted and you can
see in the timing as well
Stephen gethins thanks so much for
joining us very much appreciated